HTTPS helps prevent intruders from
tampering with the communication
between your progressive web app and
your user's browser.
It's also a stricter requirement
to use service workers.
Your app must be served over HTTPS in
order to register a service worker.
And many older APIs that may reveal
sensitive data are being updated
to require HTTPS, such as the geo
location API and gate user media.
For deploying your weather app,
there are a number of options.
You can add HTTPS to your own server.
There's a great source free
certificates in the instructor notes.
Or you can use one of the hosting
providers that offer HTTPS by default.
GitHub pages and Firebase both
support static hosting over HTTPS.
And the Google Cloud
platform offers app engine.
Which can support HTTPS and is useful
if you need any back end logic.
One thing I really like
about Firebase's hosting
is that it redirects
all requests to HTTPS.
Even if a user types in HTTP://,
it will automatically
redirect to the secure url.
let's walk through the steps
to deploy the Firebase.
I've already created my account and
added a new project.
And I've already installed
the Firebase command line tools.
If you haven't worked with Firebase
before, check out the link to
the hosting docs in the instructor notes
for a quick getting starting guide.
First, I need to authenticate to
the Firebase command line tool
using Firebase login.
Next I need to initialize my Firebase
app by running Firebase init.
I'll give it the app name
that it should deploy to,
the directory I want it to upload and
so forth.
Finally, I can run Firebase deploy and
it will upload everything to Firebase.
Let's give it a try.
>> If you haven't worked with Firebase
before, check the link to the hosting
docks and the instructor notes for
a quick getting started guide.
First, I need to authenticate
the Firebase command line
using Firebase log in.
Great, success.
Next, I need to initialize my
Firebase up by running Firebase init.
I'll give it the name of
the app it should use.
The directory I wanted to upload and
so forth.
Finally, I can run Firebase,
deploy and it'll upload everything.
Let's give it a try.
Looks perfect.
>> Perfect.
Seems like everything
worked exactly as I expect